BEN ABBOTT: This is our
second chance tournament.
Up first, the runner-up duel.
Both of you guys came
this close to winning
your rounds last time, but you
didn't quite seal the deal.
The duels start now.
My name is Rick Rabjohn.
I'm 58 years old.
The last time I was here, it
was the balance of my sword
that did me in.
I wish I would have won.
And that's why I'm
back here again today.
Give it another go.
I'm Michael Seronde.
I'm from Tucson, Arizona.
Last time I was here,
It was so close.
It would mean so much to me
if I make it through this duel
to the final round.
I'd really love a second shot.
Since you guys both
came in second place
last time you were
here, we've decided
to make this competition
all about twos.
Today, we do not want
you to make a blade,
we want you to make two
different blades, a Damascus
dagger and a Damascus chopper.
Your duel starts now.
RICK RABJOHN: They're
two very different blade.
One built for, you know,
stabbing and slicing,
and the other one,
built for chopping.
Dagger is a little more
complicated than the chopper.
I got the chopper to length
and pretty much to width.
Ooh.
As the clock is ticking,
I wish I was a little
bit further with these blades.
But as I'm grinding,
I'm realizing
that, hey, you know what,
the forge walls went well,
I'm feeling pretty good.
I'm going to move
on to the quench.
All right, well,
he's got one in there.
Yay.
I'm delighted I've
got to hardened blades.
Now I got to temper it.
All right, Rick is
working on his handle.
That's good.
I'm going to do full
tang, so, in this way,
I just put scales on
both sides of the tang
and leave it at that.
I've got that done.
Now, we work on this one.
He's got a handle
on his dagger,
and now, he's putting a
handle onto his chopper.
RICK RABJOHN: As the
clock is ticking,
I still have a lot of work
to do to shape the handles
and put the final sharpening.
It's going to come
right down to the wire,
but I'm confident
I'm going to make it.
We got Rick etching.
Oh, good.
Right on.
You can color me impressed.
Told him to make two blades.
That is one hell of a feat.
Biggest concern
is making two knives
out of Damascus in five hours.
That's out of control.
I've never done that before.
Instead of just sitting
looking at the steel heat up,
I have time to get my
handle materials ready.
Look how much Mike has
already accomplished.
[inaudible] drawn out to
almost being blade size.
At this point, my knives
are really taking shape.
They look solid.
Now, it's time to quench.
The time constraints
are a little bit
challenging, heat treating
two blades back to back.
I need to nail my heat treat.
Boom.
After quenching my chopper, I
don't think it's hard enough.
This file doesn't skate quite
as easily as I wanted to.
HOST: Second quench.
Put some bunch of
stress on his blade.
I have to do it again.
This time, it works.
I don't have any
more time to waste.
It's time to move
on to the dagger.
It's a little bit thinner.
It has two cutting edges.
So I have to make sure
that heat is even more
even than it was in my chopper.
All right, dagger is quenched.
It's straight.
I've got a chunk of
mesquite wood from earlier.
And I have to attach
handles to two knives.
There is a lot of work to
do in not very much time.
I've got to get going.
I have a dagger on a 2
inch square block handle.
That is not going to fly.
I blast through the block trying
to get that handle to something
that is comfortable enough.
Key is enough.
I'm trying to dribble
a little bit of glue
because I'm afraid I don't have
enough epoxy to make everything
stick together right.
I'm at the grinder with both
my dagger and my chopper.
At this stage, I feel like
I'm sprinting between tasks,
and I keep bouncing
between these two knives.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Gentlemen, turn
off the machines.
Put down your tools.
This duel is over.
[claps]
Good job.
[exhales]
All right, runners up,
it's time for our doubled up
strength test, stab and chop.
I'm going to take your daggers,
stab them into a stump here.
And then I'll take your
choppers and attack
both the post and the skulls.
Michael, you're
up first on this.
Are you ready?
Ah, yes.
OK.
[whispers] It didn't break.
It did not break.
All right, Mike,
start with your dagger.
Right off, the weight and
feel of this blade, I mean,
this is super comfortable.
I could play with this all day.
It's got a wicked edge
and a wicked point
on it, which I really like.
I poked it in there.
It dug in deep and held up fine.
What I don't like is that
leather spacer you put in here,
you then covered
it with Krazy Glue.
That turned it into
some sharp edges.
When you're thrusting
into something,
it's not really a good thing.
As far as your chopper goes,
again, nice weight on this.
You didn't take
really any damage.
This is still a
wicked sharp blade.
So all in all, nice set.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, Rick,
you're up next.
You good?
Yeah.
All right, let's do it.
[music playing]
[claps] That's great.
So right off the bat,
this is a heavy dagger.
There's a lot of metal there.
Um, what really got me was
all this right around here,
there are kind of
sharp jagged edges.
And since the handle doesn't
really have any contouring,
there's no way to
keep off that guard.
Now, on your chopper, again,
that's a lot of material there.
But it does have an edge, and
that edge didn't take damage.
So that's great.
They held up very, very well.
So good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, we
know your weapons are strong,
but are they sharp?
This is the water tube slice and
the canvas bag stab and slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
we'll take your weapons and
slash across these water
tubes and canvas bag.
Double your weapons, double
the slice, double the nice.
[laughter]
Mike, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Oh, yeah.
All right, let's do this.
[music playing]
Ooh.
Beautiful.
[laughs] [claps]
All right, Michael, off the
bat, these feel really good.
Even though they are
two different designs,
they feel equally
balanced on both hands,
and they are wicked sharp.
On the slash on the water
tubes, very clean slice.
You have a sharp edge here, sir.
Also, on the stabbing and
slashing with your dagger,
those are very clean cuts.
Overall, sir, both your
weapons, they will cut.
[laughs] Sweet.
HOST: All right, Rick,
are you ready, sir?
No.
[laughter]
Well, we're going
to do it anyways.
We're going to do it.
[laughter]
[music playing]
[laughs]
[exhales]
All right, Rick, let's
talk about your weapons here.
First up, these
are heavy beasts.
And even for a dagger, it's
very forward heavy weight.
Same with your chopper,
as a chopper is expected.
For a dagger, it's
very heavy, but I
was still able to cut cleanly.
You have a sharp edge
on your chopper here.
Overall, sir, they will cut.
Thank you.
HOST: Good job.
Very well done, gentlemen.
[laughter]
But only one of you
guys can leave here
with a check for
$2,000 and a spot
in the final leg of this
second chance tournament.
The bladesmith who won
this duel is Michael.
Congratulations.
You're moving forward
into the final round
of the second shot tournament.
Unfortunately, Rick,
that means you're
not going to be moving forward.
I'm going to have to
ask you to please leave.
OK, take care, man.
I'll see you.
Good job.
Last time my
competitors blade was
just better balanced than mine.
I still can't get it right.
I agree with the
judge's decision,
but I'm also proud of what
I accomplished in getting
through this tough challenge.
It was fun and always good
to meet other bladesmiths.
And once again, it's
been a great experience.
And if there's a third
chance tournament, I'm in.
Michael, congratulations, man.
That means you broke
the second place curse,
and you came out on top
of your duel, which also
means you're moving forward
into the final round
of our tournament.
And you are leaving here
with a check for $2,000,
so congratulations,
man, very well done.
Thank you.
We will see you for the
second round of this tournament.
Winning feels incredible.
This challenge was
the hardest smithing
challenge I've ever done.
Knowing that, I can't even
begin to imagine what's next.
The next stage of
this competition
is going to be that much harder.
Every one of the smiths in the
next round have already won.
So I know they're going
to bring their best.
I have to bring my best.
It's going to be brutal.